hi there mr. wonderful here there's
nothing more stressful than a money
dispute whether it's with a business
partner or a family member and in these
extraordinary times the stakes are
higher than ever but you know what you
don't need that stress you don't need
that heartache you need resolution so
I'm here to give it to you
to be your bridge from conflict to peace
and with that let's get started we've
got a question for Jordan here which is
I think a question a lot of people are
going to relate to it's happening all
over America hey Kevin Jordan from New
Jersey here how are you huge fan I am in
a dispute with my gym I spent $900 on
painting sessions and then this
coronavirus happened the gyms been
closed for two months and they won't
give me my money back I'd be fine with a
we're so sorry I trough tough times
here's an extra four sessions when we
reopen fine I would take it very happy
to tell me that you're not giving me a
refund just emails me back it is like no
no no no no no but that is so nasty and
I can't take when businesses take
advantage of the situation and they're
not customer focused Kevin I need your
help with this I'm in a huge coup fawful
with this place please help Jordan I
can't stand nasty cough offals as you
call it and surely there's got to be a
resolution to this let's be pragmatic
the guy's running a gym operation nobody
can see the pandemic coming I get that
you probably have no contract because
this is really a relationship between a
trainer and you in a gym I'm going to
guess that so basically this is about
what's fair for the business proprietors
the trainers you got to be fair you got
to offer your time and service to your
clients and they will not forget Jordans
not going to forget if you do that
they're gonna make sure that they work
with you going forward because you cared
about them at a time when they couldn't
work with you directly in a gym so I
reached out to your gym and they got
back to me let me tell you what they
said it's good news my friend all
clients have been offered the
opportunity to train virtually with
their trainer to use the sessions while
we are closed or they can use them in
person when we reopen they will get the
service that they paid for Jordan that's
a key
we are hoping for an early June
reopening hey Jordan they didn't offer
your money back but they did offer the
service and one way to resolve this
thing is you simply ask for a couple
more virtual lessons that would seem
fair to me the point is they're willing
to meet in the middle and that's a good
thing I think this is a good outcome
okay I have a question from Jason here
and this one's a toughy I'm a commercial
landlord but I only own two properties
so when tenants don't pay it causes huge
problems for me yeah I totally get that
totally get that
that's cash flow well one tenant is a
gigantic nationwide chain I wonder who
that could be and their corporate office
just sent a letter stating that due to
kovat 19 they're going to stop paying
full rent as of June 1st hmm I think
it's insane that a huge corporation is
trying to shift its burden onto a little
guy like me I know that if I take them
to court I'd most likely win but I can't
afford it what do I do
Jason my friend I'm dealing with 51
companies I'm an investor in 29 of which
are in disputes with landlords I'm
seeing both sides of this issue everyday
and dealing with it it's really hard but
let me give you some immediate advice
here having gone through it so many
times you have to be very genteel in how
you deal with the situation do you
really want to bite the hand that feeds
you think about it they're basically
asking you probably to defer the rent in
other words they have no traffic they
have no income and if you were to
negotiate with them and say look it's
unfair to me to take on the entire
economic burden can I extend the lease
or at least three months or what could
we meet halfway or anything in between
is better than saying I'm going to sue
you not a good idea of it's a national
chain so in this case here's what's
going to happen number one you're gonna
write a letter back saying thank you for
informing me of this but you're putting
me under stress because I'm a small guy
and I've been a great landlord to you
that's number one number two you're
going to make a suggestion of where you
meet in the middle number three and make
sure you put this in there that you've
appreciated
as a tenant and you look forward for
better times they'll understand what
you're saying there that is the right
thing to do here but don't just sit in
silence contemplating litigation not a
good idea don't sue the hand that feeds
you
remember I said that and good luck to
you all right I have a question in
videoed from Suzanne on a very complex
issue
have a listen this is my story I have
three products I developed just me no
business partners no rich husbands and
Malibu financing anything just me but
first products on the market selling
great second and third product I wanted
to try and get a patent on so I hide a
patent attorney she suggested and it
seemed quite common sense to do a patent
search to see yes or no would there be
any reason on the market why these
patents would be tonight so I did that
and the results came back saying it
looks good so let's do it fast forward
two years both patent applications
denied reject it and this is what I
found out there is a law a very small
but important law that if any product is
advertised or sold 12 months prior to a
patent application patent applications
invalid they just deny it flat out
now you would think as have happened to
tarnish you would know this and she
would advise as legal counsel any people
that she was representing so I don't
know she's either a complete scam artist
or completely incompetent either which
way no way no I would love my money back
I worked really hard for my money and
it's not a lot of money to a lot of
people but it's a lot of money to me so
please how I write Suzanne very
interesting case here in a nutshell
you're telling me basically your
attorney went and pursued a patent even
though it would have been very easy to
find out prior art or commercial as you
said happen 12 months earlier to me that
sounds like incompetence to me it sounds
like they tried to milk you with fees
that's what it sounds like if what
you've told me is correct you've got a
very interesting case here so here's
what's going to happen the only path you
have unless you want to spend
a lot of time and money in litigation
which the outcome is never clear is to
simply write a letter that contains this
you detailer that letter exactly what
you told me on this date I called you
and hired you to pursue a patent you
told me you were going to do prior art
search that's what it's called you
blatantly missed a commercial only
twelve months old which never happens I
feel that you have really taken
advantage of me as a small business and
it's not right and then suggest what
would make you happy and make you go
away as somebody's gonna be a combatant
or complaint
I would ask fifty percent of my money
back and be happy if I got that by the
way Suzanne that's a three paragraph
letter don't make it any longer than
that it's that simple to put that out
there and then call them up a week later
and ask them what do they want to do
because this is not right it just isn't
mr. wonderful here join me Wednesday for
a special event when the next webisode
of my new series streams live on YouTube
I'll do what I do best solve your money
disputes submitted by you like when I
take on Neiman Marcus girlfriend two
hundred thousand dollars worth of
jewelry or you say what a mess and oh
yes mr. Wonderful's calls always dancer
join me and I'll be answering all your
questions Wednesday at 2:00 Eastern go
to cnbc.com slash youtube live I have a
question from Denise and this is very
interesting I think you're going to have
to follow me through the different
levels of the onion on this one ready
here we go
I'm gonna go slowly so you stay with me
this is about a golf cart I feel I
should inherit my mother-in-law quote
unquote was dating my brother-in-law's
dad brother-in-law's dad okay but after
she died and left behind her golf cart
my brother-in-law
kept it because he said he put a new
battery in it and was going to use it
that's the setup
he said she wanted to have it but in
fact he hated her and always talked
about her behind her back I'm now not
even speaking with my sister because of
this they're rich enough to buy 12 golf
carts and we are not what is your advice
well I'm fascinated I mean there's a lot
going on here there's clearly family
there's a golf cart there's capital
expenditures in a new battery on the
golf cart but I understand fair is fair
you thought your promise the golf cart
and now you have a family member that
said no I'm not giving it to you all
right let's try to put a value on this
thing it's a used golf cart with a new
battery what's that worth if it was the
rolls-royce of golf carts maybe 2,500 in
reality on this one
500 bucks maybe is it really worth
fighting about I don't think so
this isn't a child it's a golf cart I've
got a video from a me and I've getting
so many just like this video oh my
goodness I feel for these people hi my
name is Amy and I am a parent I'd say
middle school here in Miami Florida the
reason why I'm reaching out for help
today is because on March 15 the
students were supposed to take a trip to
Washington DC with a well known
nonprofit organization because of the
virus because oh come on a virus the
trip was first postponed and then later
on canceled now this is an eighth grade
trip the students will be moving from
middle school to high school next year
so it's not a trip that we can
reschedule it's not really an option for
us well we are asking which give us a
full refund of what we paid in my case I
paid a thousand five hundred and fifty
five dollars but I know that there's
some parents that ended up paying a
little bit more than that I think it's
only fair and it's only right procane
nonprofit organization to give us back
100 percent refund Amy here's the
problem this is not a for-profit
business this is a charity basically
that's trying to make great experiences
happen for kids in middle school they're
altruistic they're not after you to make
money what's probably happened here Amy
is they've already spent money just
organizing the trip that money is gone
so here's what you're going to do you're
going to write a letter to every member
of the board of that nonprofit and
because it's a non-profit and its public
you can get that information off their
website everybody on that board is going
to get the same letter and they're going
to know that everybody else got the
letter you're powerful
me letter is power you're going to
explain right out of the gate that you
wrote a check expecting to send your
child to Washington the pandemic it
didn't happen you don't want to credit
it's useless to you and the rest of the
families because your children are
moving on they can't use it so you
understand in the letter you're going to
say that the nonprofit probably spent
some money setting it up you don't
expect that back you're willing to take
less than a hundred cents on the dollar
but you want the rest I think you're
gonna find out they'll give you whatever
cash is still there and I think that's a
fair outcome to this situation Amy good
luck I've got a business question from a
kid he's name is August it's an email
let's check it out I'm a kid mowing
lawns I have a 50-50 partnership with
the other kid next door even though I do
all the bookkeeping and everything else
outside mowing the problem I want out I
have no control over our schedule
because I always have to wait for him to
finish baseball practice before we can
mow I want to be paid extra for the
bookkeeping but he refuses because he
says he could do it all - except he
doesn't oh I feel the tension I want to
be paid extra for the pickup truck I
bought for the business but he says it's
my truck and has nothing to do with him
how do I end this thing just so you know
our estimated 2020 revenues is twenty
thousand dollars yeah you got a business
kiddo and you got problems to your
partner let me explain something about
partnerships August when you form a
partnership with somebody and this could
be in business or in life a like your
wife maybe you are forming a bond you
are forming a relationship and it's
based on a 50/50 idea now what you're
complaining about is your partner's
letting you down not carrying half the
weight but that doesn't mean you can
just walk away if you want to end this
thing with him you got to buy him out
you're making twenty thousand dollars
maybe you're gonna give him five of it
and it's sayonara if he says no you know
what you do talk to his parents explain
the situation that their son is not
cooperating with you but you wanted
the right thing help them mediate a deal
your reputation is everything
August remember this kid is your
next-door neighbor so how you handle
does everything he's not going away he's
living right beside you you want to wake
up the morning after you end the
relationship in the business and still
have him as your neighbor and a friend
once that's over with go find another
partner and build the business you keep
doing the books you keep doing the
marketing and you hire other people to
mow the lawns now that's what I'm
talking about and I know you've got it
because you're already making $20,000
you're doing way better than the guy
that used to deliver papers 20,000 bucks
you can make it a hundred and twenty
thousand you make it two hundred and
fifty thousand you need to lever
yourself you're an entrepreneur my
friend I want you to go make it happen
all right I've got a video from Joran
and this is about love and mr. wonderful
loves love that's why I'm in the wedding
business you know two times in life
where you don't care about margins or
price when you get married when you die
I'm in both businesses love them oh well
let's hear from Jory
hello mr. wonderful I went and I bought
a ring for my girlfriend to become my
fiancee and I'm trying to be quiet
because she's right upstairs so you know
Shh don't tell her but um I went and
bought a ring spent 6,500 bucks on it
jeweler claims he never got the payment
I have bank statements saying that it
was taken check was cashed accepted is
sixty-five hundred bucks
make or break money you know not to
everybody but it's the principle of me
not being able to call my girlfriend my
fiance and just calling her my
girlfriend I hope you know how truly
blessed I am to have this woman in my
life and I'd do anything to buy her ring
if it's another sixty five hundred bucks
I got to spend I'm I'd spend it every
day the week because I love her that
much but I wanted to send you this video
letting you know what was going on and I
can't wait to hear a response from you I
love the fact you're putting love over
money there's only one time in your life
where you can do that when you're
falling in love it's so euphoric it's so
wonderful I feel great for you on that
now let's talk about the dispute three
things you're gonna do right now sit
your fiance down tell her the whole
story you know great weddings have
mystique and
history to them and you've got a heck of
a story here you basically bought her a
ring in good faith and never got
delivery I think that's gonna be a story
you're gonna tell your grandchildren
it's fantastic and still you got married
and still you're together
that's the hopeful outcome number two
let's talk about the money you're going
to send a letter into their customer
complaint department with all your
information including the canceled check
and say you've never got delivery some
employee in there is going to try and
figure it out believe me they don't want
to defraud people because you're also
going to say in that complaint if you
don't get results within a week you're
gonna go public with it and you're gonna
start posting all over the place that
this company basically stole from you
that's fair to say one way another
you're getting your money back is just a
matter of time but really what I hope is
this ends up lamode a whoa whoa whoa
whoa I love love that's why they call me
mr. wonderful join me Wednesday for a
special event when the next webisode of
my new series screams live on YouTube
join me and I'll be answering all your
questions Wednesday at 2:00 Eastern go
to cnbc.com slash youtube live